[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نصائب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
في اوكرانيا تفجير سد كخوفكا يهدد محطه
وسر توقيت التفجير في اخبار الساعه
وزير الطاقه السعوديه يعلن دخول مشروع
الربط الكهربائي بين دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي والعراق حيز التنفيذ
بحضور جماهري كبير في استاد الجوهره نادي
اتحاد جده يقدم لاعبه الجديد كريم بنزيما
واشنطن ولندن تطلقان شراكه اقتصاديه جديده
لمواجهه طموحات الصين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه اعلن الشركه
المشغله لسدك خوفكا ان الخزانه الذي تم
انشاؤه بواسطه السد في جنوب اوكرانيا لا
يمكنه توفير المياه للتبريد مفاعلات محطه
النوويه وقال المدير التنفيذي للشركه
المشغله للسد ايجار سيراتا ان منسوب
المياه اقل من النقطه في الفاصله البالغه
12.7 مترا ما يعني انه لم يعد ممكنا امداد
الاحواض في محطه
النوويه لتبريد المحطه
كشف اربعه مسؤولين اوكرانيا لصحيفه واشنطن
الامريكيه ان الهجوم المضاد الذي طال
انتظاره اقد بدا لاستعاده سياده دوله
اوكرانيا وفق المسؤولين الاربعه الذين
يعملون في القوات المسلحه فان القوات
الاوكرانيه كثفت هجماتها على طول خط
المواجهه في جنوب شرق البلاد وذلك بهدف
تحرير مدينتي
سيطرت عليهما روسيا ضمن عمليتها العسكريه
الخاصه
قائد مجموعه العسكريه الروسيه قال من جهته
ان المعارك على الجبهه تؤكد ان اوكرانيا
بدات هجومها المضاد واوضحت صحفيه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تكثف هجومها على جبهات
القتال كما تم التخطيط له وعرب قائد فاجنر
عن اعماله في ان تتمكن القوات الروسيه من
التعامل مع هذا الهجوم وصده مؤكدا ثقته في
الجيش الروسي
وزير الدفاع الروسي سايجو اعلن عن توجيه
ضربه وقائيه بالمدفعيه والطيران والاسلحه
المضاده للدبابات بعد محاوله اختراق فاشله
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه في جميع
الاتجاهات الاربعه على حد وصفح
حول العدو اختراق دفاعاتنا بقوات اللواء
الميكانيكي السابع والاربعين والذي يصل
تعداده الى 1500 فرد ومائه وخمسين عربه
مدرعه
تم اكتشاف العدو في الوقت المناسب من قبل
قوات الاستطلاع وتم توجيه الضربه الوقائيه
بالمدفعيه والطيران والاسلحه المضاده
للدبابات في جميع الاتجاهات الاربعه تم
ايقاف العدو وتراجع مع خسائر فادحه وقوات
العدو الاحتياطيه المدربه خصيصا لتنفيذ
هذا الاختراق لم تنجز مهمتها
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد او الصامت كما
بات يعرف يبدو انه قد بدا بالفعل وفق ما
نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين
عسكريين اوكرانيين وعلى ما يبدو ان ملامح
الهجوم المضاد بدات تتكشف حيث اشار
المسؤولون الى ان الهجمات كثفت في مناطق
بجنوب شرقي البلاد
وبحسب الصحيفه فان الهدف الرئيسي هو قطع
طريق البري الرئيسي بين شبه جزيره القرم
وجنوب روسيا اهم طرق الامدادات الروسيه
والجبهه الاكثر ترجيحا ستكون في زبروجيا
وهي الجبهه التي شهدت الساعات الماضيه
هجوما للقوات الاوكرانيه على القوات
الروسيه
وبحسب وزير الدفاع الروسي فان الهجوم نفذه
اللواء سبعه واربعون ميكانيكيين اوكراني
وهو كلمه السر في الهجوم المضاد المنتظر
اللواء يبلغ تعداده 1500 جندي و150 مدرعه
تلقى تدريبات لاشهر في قاعده للنيتو
بالمانيا
اكتسب خبره ومهارات في تكتيكات النيتو
الحربيه الاكثر تقدما وهو مسلح باسلحه
ومعدات وتقنيات غربيه
قياده اللواء تدربت على اجهزتك كمبيوتر
تحاكي المواقف التي قد يواجهونها في
المعارك الواقعيه ودرسوا نتائج المحاكاه
وبحسب واشنطن بوست فان اللواء سبعه
واربعين نقل الى موقع سري اقرب الى خط
الجبهه بعد تسليح وتدريب للقتال مثل
الجيوش الغربيه لكن بمفردهم ذاك اختبار
للاستراتيجيه التي تقودها الولايات
المتحده تقول موسكو على لسان وزير الدفاع
ان هذه القوه المدربه خصيصا لتحقيق اختراق
فشلت بمهمتها والحقت بها خسائر كبيره
سيوله مياه سد كخوفكا تغرق صراع الروسيه
الاوكرانيه في وحل الكوارث الانسانيه
والبيئيه الخطيره اسئله كثيره لم تجد لها
اجوبه حتى الان حول المسؤول عن التفجير
وخصوصا المستفيد من تبعاته على المستوى
العسكري على الاقل فموسكو تتهموذ بتدمير
السد من اجل قطع المياه عن اقليم القرم
بينما تقول ان القوات الروسيه نفذت
للتفجير لتعطيل هجومها المضاد للمرتقب
صحيفه البريطانيه حاولت تحليل تبعات هذا
التفجير وخلصت الى انه سيؤدي الى الحد من
خيارات الهجوم المضاد لك
صحيفه استندت في تحليلها الى توقيت تنفيذ
الهجوم والذي لا يخدم مصالح اوكرانيا
الراغبه في تنفيذ الهجوم المضاد ويرى
محللون عسكريون والمسؤولون اوكران تحدثوا
للصحيفه البريطانيه ان تدمير السد شتته
تركيز كييف وغطى على اخبار الهجوم المضاد
كما اضافت الصحيفه ان الفيضانات التي تسبب
فيها السد من شانها افشال خطط كييف في
الهجوم على المنطقه الجنوبيه على الاقل
وبالتالي فان اوكرانيا ستكتفي بمهاجمه
المنطقه الشرقيه ما يسمح لموسكو بتركيز
اهتمامها على هذه الجبهه
تفجير السد فضلا عن تحركات موسكو العسكريه
الاخيره فتح النقاش ايضا عن فائده تلويح
كيابل المستمر بعزمها تنفيذه هجوم المضاد
وهو ما سمح لموسكو بتجهيز نفسها بهذا
الخصوص نقلت الصحيفه ايضا تصريحا لمايكل
وهو محلل عسكري امريكي مختص في الشؤون
الروسيه والذي استغرب من تفاجئ كييف من
تفجير السد علما انها ظلت تعلن مرارا انها
على وشك شن هجوم مضاد وبغض النظر عن
الفائده العسكريه لهذا التفجير فان
انعكاساته السلبيه ستطل الجانب الروسي
ايضا فحسب الصحيفه ادت الفيضانات الى غمر
خط الدفاع الروسي شرق نهر دنيفرو في خرسون
ينضم الينا من موسكو في
الدبلوماسيه السابق وعبر سكايب من كيابل
الخبير بالشؤون الاوكرانيه يحيى خربطلي
مرحبا بكما ضيفي الكريمين سيد ماتوز ابداء
معك في موسكو هل هذا التزامن عن بدء
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد كما تنقل الصحيفه
الامريكيه وتفجير سد كخوفكا هل هذا
التزامن يعني شيئا
اولا كل هذا الحدث خبر يعني مطلع من جريده
واشنطن بورس الذي نشرت
مش مقالات بس تعليقات من منذ اليوم صباحا
حول امكانيه البدء الهجوم
مضاد او هجوم كما يسمى نحن نسميه في منطقه
ولذلك هذا خبر من وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
ولا وسائل اعلام الروسيه اوكرانيه حتى
ينشروا اي خبر حول هذا
موضوع
خبراء الاوكرانيين من كيف عملوا تحليل
خبراء العسكريين في مصر هو اعطت صوره انه
احتمال وارد ولكن هل بد ات فعلا هذا
الهجوم اوكرانيا او لا
وطبعا طرف اوكرانيا يعتبر انه
هجوم يمكن ان بدات يمكن دعني اسال هذا
السؤال لضيفي منظف لو سمحت لي سيد يحيى
خربط لي هل حقا بدا الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد
مساء الخير
المشاهدين الكرام وبضيفك الكريم من موسكو
اودنا نقول بان ربما هذا
الهجوم المعاكسه الذي
انتظر طويلا قد بدا ليس اليوم وليس قبل
ايام او يومين او ثلاثه وانما بدا قبل ذلك
بكثير علما بان القياده العسكريه سواء
القياده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه او السياسيه كانت تقول بانها
ليست جاهزه لبدء هذا الهجوم ولكن اذا
رجعنا الى قبل ايام او قبل اسابيع مثلا
عندما تم اطلاق طائرات مسيره التي وصلت
الى مشارف الكريم وتفجرت هناك عدا عن ذلك
هناك مجموعات يقال انها تخريبيه للمتطوعين
العسكريين الروسي الذين يحاربون الى جانب
الجيش الاوكراني دخلوا الى مناطق حدوديه
مع اوكرانيا والتي هي ولا زالوا موجودين
في هذه المناطق ويجرينا
معارك مع الجيش الروسي او بالاحرى يعني
المعارك طبعا غير كبيره بما ان ليس
لا وجود للجيش الروسي بشكل مكثف في هذه
المناطق فبالتالي من هنا نقدر وقبل ايام
او مثلا امس او اول امس
حتى
القاده العسكريين اعترفوا منهم
اعترف بان الهجوم المعاكس الاوكراني قد
بدا لكن بتقديري ان هذه الهجوم كما قلت
وشرحت لك بانه بدا يعني ولم يعني لم يكن
ببال القياده القياده الاوكرانيه
بالتصريح عن تاريخ بدا هذا
الهجوم المضاده
وكما وكما راينا من خلال
تقريركم الاخباري هناك يعني كان الضباط او
الجنود او يعني الكثير من الناس المسؤولين
كانوا
يفعلون هكذا بما معناه ان التكتم عن تاريخ
هذا الهجوم اشكرك شكرا جزيلا يحيى خربطلي
الخبير في الشؤون الاوكرانيه كنت معنا من
كييف ومن موسكو في
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه السابق
[موسيقى]
احتفل الدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي والعراق
في مدينه الخبر السعوديه باعلان بدء مشروع
الربط الكهربائي الخليجي بين دول مجلس
التعاون والعراق يذكر ان تشغيل المشروع
سيكون مع نهايه العام المقبل وسيزود
المشروع جنوب العراق بالطاقه الكهربائيه
حيث سيكون باكوره التعاون والتبادل
التجاري بين دول مجلس التعاون والعراق
بحسب هيئه الربط الكهربائي الخليجي ويتكون
المشروع من ثلاث مراحل حيث تبدا المرحله
الاولى بتجهيز محافظه البصره بجنوب العراق
بجهد 500
في مرحله متقدمه
وخلال الحفل اكد وزير طاقه السعوديه عبد
العزيز بن سلمان ان الربط الكهربائي بين
دول الخليج والعراق يحقق فوائد اقتصاديه
ملموسه
في هذا كله هو عمل يعزز قدره العراق على
تلبيه تحتاجات
الاقتصاد العراقي الشقيق من الكهرباء في
السنوات القادمه كما سيعزز امن واستقرار
الشبكات الكهربائيه المترابطه واود هنا ان
نعبر عن تقديري
وتقديم العمل لتقديم العمل في المشروع
كهرباء ربط الكهربائي السعودي في العراق
المباشر الذي يشرف عليه فريق عمل مشترك من
المملكه ومن العراق
ومن جهته اكد وزير الكهربائي العراقي زياد
فاضل على الاهميه الاستراتيجيه لمشروع
الربط الكهربائي الجديد
وضع الحجر الاساسي لمشروع الربط الذي
يتضمن تنفيذ خط بدائرتين من محطه الزور
الثانويه مرورا مرورا بمحطه الوفره الى
محطه الفاو وبطول كلي 322 كيلومتر وان
مقدار الطاقه المتوقعه المتوقعه استيرادها
من خلال هذه الخط كمرحله الاولى سيبلغ 500
ميجا واط لتغذيته محافظه البصره
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان على التزام جميع المشاركين في
الاجتماع الوزاري للتحالف الدولي في الحد
من مصادر تمويل الارهابي ووسائل نشره
مشددا على ان سبل اعاده الاستقرار في
الاراضي المحرره من تنظيم داعش في سوريا
والعراق كانت من اولويات التحالف خلال
الاجتماعاتنا اليوم ناقشنا سبل اعاده
استقرار في الاراضي المحرره للتنظيم داعش
في سوريا والعراق باعتبارها من ضمن قائمات
لدى التحالف واكدنا على اهميه استمرار
الجهود في هذا الاطار كما اكد المشاركون
على الالتزامهم واستمرارهم في الحد من
مصادر التمويل الارهاب ووسائل نشره
والترويج كما تجد الاشاره هنا اذا تراس
المملكه لمجموعه مكافحه التمويل داعش
وجهودها الكبيره في اطار تنسيق عمل كافه
الدول في التحالف للتصدي لتمويل هذا
التنظيم كما بحثنا الاجراءات التي يمكن
اتباعها لمجابه الارهاب والميليات المسلحه
في غرب افريقيا ودول الساحل ووسط وجنوب
افريقيا
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه البيت الابيض
ينفي تقريرا عن اقتراب امريكا وايران من
اتفاق نووي مؤقت
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد نفى البيت الابيض
تقريرا اعلاميا نفاد بان الولايات المتحده
وايران تقتربان من اتفاق مؤقت تقلص طهران
بموجبه برنامجها النووي مقابل تخفيف
العقوبات عنها وصف متحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي بالبيت الابيض التقرير بالمضلل في
اشاره الى مقال بموقع ميدل اس اي
الالكتروني نقل معلومات غير صحيحه عن
مصادر لم يحدده هويتها
[موسيقى]
علقت الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه
المساعدات الغذائيه لاثيوبيا واكدت
الوكاله في بيان لها انها لن تقدم
المساعدات الانسانيه الى ان تطبق
الاصلاحات نضيفه انها تستانف المساعدات
فور عوده الانظمه
الخاصه بمساعده المحتجي
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده انها اخذت علما بالاتفاق
بين الاطراف الليبيه على الاحكام
القانونيه التي تشكل اطارا للانتخابات
المفترض اجراءها بحلول نهايه
مؤكده انها تعمل على حل نقاط الخلاف
العالقه ودعت الامم المتحده الخصومه
السياسيين الى الالتزام بروح التسويه بحل
جميع القضايا العالقه وخلق بيئه اكثر
امانا واكثر ملائمه لاجراء انتخابات في
عام 2023
[موسيقى]
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسونا شراكه
اقتصاديه جديده بين البلدين تهدف الى حوض
التحديات الجيو السياسيه الكبيره الراهنه
وخصوصا في مواجهه طموحات الصين وينص اعلان
الاطلسي على بنود عده على عده بنود بينها
تعزيز التعاون في صناعه الدفاع وتوليد
المعادن الضروريه في الانتقال على صعيد
الطاقه
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده ملامح المنافسه داخل
الحزب الجمهوري على الانتخابات الرئاسيه
تتضح شيئا فشيئا الرئيس الجمهوري السابق
دونالد ترامب الذي كان معروفا ترشحه يجد
امامه لحد الان 11 منافسا راغبا في الفوز
بثقه الحزب الجمهوري وتبقى حظوظه بعض
هؤلاء المرشحين قائمه نوعا ما رغم ان كفه
ترامب هيل الارجح بلغه الاستطلاعات
الامري
كيه فما
هي هذه الاسماء
الرئيس الامريكي السابق صاحب الحظوظ
الاوفر حسب استطلاعات
الرايس حكموا ولايه فلوريدا اكتسب شعبيه
كبيره في السنوات الاخيره مايك بانس
النائب السابق للرئيس ترامب لا يحظى
بقاعده جمهوريه واسعه
الحاكم السابق لولايه نيوجيرسي ابدى رغبه
واضحه في عرقله
يطمح في ان يصبح اول رئيس جمهوري من اصل
افريقي
كثيرون يرون ان السباق على الفوز بترشيح
الحزب الجمهوري محسوم لصالح ترامب وان
كانت سيجد اي منافسه جمهوريه فلن تكون سوى
من حاكم ولايه فلوريدا
يشير اخر استطلاع للراي اجرته رويترز
بمشاركه مؤسسه الاستشاريه الى تفوق ترامب
بنسبه 49% بينما يتوقع ان يحصل ديسانتس
على 19% من الاصوات اما بالنسبه لباقي
المرشحين فحظوظهم تبقى ضعيفه حيث حصل على
خمسه في المئه فقط ونكهه على اربعه في
المئه فقط وواحد بالمئه لكل من كرستي
وسكوت
[موسيقى]
غبار وحرائقي كندا يخنق سكان امريكا
الشماليه ويتسبب في اسوا حاله تلوث في
العالم عشرات الملايين من سكان امريكا
الشماليه تلقوا تحذيرات من خطوره سوء جوده
الهواء بسبب الحرائق المنتشره في كندا ولا
يزال الدخان يغطي مناطق واسعه من اونتاريو
وكبيك بينما يغيم ضباب برتقالي اللون فوق
معظم شمال شرقي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واضحك مدينه تورنتو ونيويورك
ضمن المدن التي تعاني من اسوا جوده هواء
في العالم في هذا الوقت
[موسيقى]
تلوث الهواء بسبب الحرائق يشكل تهديدا
حقيقيا لسكان امريكا الشماليه فنحو 100
مليون شخص في امريكا الشماليه مهددون
بالتعرض لاضرار صحيه حقيقيه بسبب سوء جوده
الهواء الجهات الرسميه بدورها سارعت الى
تحذير المواطنين حيث اصدرت وزاره البيئه
الكنديه اقوى تحذير بشان تلوث الهواء في
اوتاوا واعتبرته لانه يشكل خطرا شديدا
للغايه على صحه الناس في الوقت نفسه صنفت
وكاله حمايه البيئه الامريكيه جوده الهواء
في معظم انحاء الشمال الشرقي على انها غير
صحيه لا سيما لما يعانون بالفعل من مشكلات
في الجهاز التنفسي
عاده عندما نكون هنا في هذا المكان قرب
نصب واشنطن نستطيع ان نرى الكونجرس
الامريكي بوضوح لكن اليوم الموضوع مختلف
لان الرؤيه ضعيفه والسبب وصول دخان حرائق
كندا الى العاصمه واشنطن الذي اثر ايضا
على جوده الهواء ما دفع عمده العاصمه الى
دعوه المواطنين الى عدم البقاء في الخارج
لاوقات طويله الا اذا كانوا مضطرين لذلك
كما دعم مسؤلون امريكيون الى اتخاذ
الاحتياطات كارتداء الكمامات لعدم استنشاق
الهواء الملوث ويخشى الباحثون من ان تسبب
الجزئيات الدخانيه الصغيره باضرار تنفسيه
للاشخاص لانهم ورغم صغارها قادره على
الحاق ضرر بالمسالك التنفسيه من المتوقع
ان يصل دخان الحرائق الى الولايات الوسطى
الغربيه وايضا الى الولايات الجنوبيه
الشرقيه الى ولايه جورجيا تحديدا
مع وصول دخان حرائق غاباته كندا الى
الولايات المتحده ودول في اوروبا ما هي
المناطق المتضرره وكم سيستغرق اطفاء هذه
الحرائق وعوده الهواء لنسبته الطبيعيه
المزيد في التقرير التالي
دخان حرائق كندا يخنق جيرانها الولايات
المتحده اول المتضررين وقد لا تكون اخرهم
السلطات الكنديه اعلنت محاولتها اخماد نحو
423 حريقا نشطا
246 منها خارجه عن السيطره تسببت الحرائق
بالقضاء على حوالي ثلاثه ملايين
فيما تحولت مقاطعه
للحرائق حيث ينشط فيها 160 حريقا الى جانب
عشرات الحرائق الاخرى في البرتا وكولومبيا
البريطانيه وانتاريو دخان حرائق الغابات
القادمه من كندا سيؤثر على اكثر من 55
مليون شخص في مناطق الشمال الشرقي ووسط
الولايات المتحده ابرزها نيويورك وبوسطن
وواشنطن نيويورك المعروفه عاده بسمائها
الصافيه سجلت اسوا مؤشر لجوده الهواء
عالميا وفق موقع اي كيو ار السويسري
المختص في مراقبه حاله الهواء
بانتقال الحرائق الى غابات الولايات
المتحده المتاخمه على بعد اكثر من
5800 كم من كندا حيث تقع النرويج يتوقع ان
تدفع الرياح بدخان الحرائق الى هناك وفق
مسؤولين نرويجيين حيث سجلت جزيئات متطايره
من الدخان جنوبيا النرويج بينما تحرك
الدخان فوق جرينلاند وايسلندا منذ الاول
من يونيو الحكومه الكنديه تتوقع استمرار
نشاط الحرائق بصوره اعلى من المعتاد
وصدبابيه توقيت ومكان توقف السحب الدخانيه
وعوده الهواء لطبيعته لارتباطها باتجاه
الرياح وسرعتها
[موسيقى]
وضع جديد للاجئين والمهاجرين يلوحوا في
الافق داخل القاره العجوز العجوز فالمصير
المشترك لدول القاره دفعها لتوحيد جهودها
بحثا عن ابرام اتفاقيه جديده تخصه ملف
الهجره دول السبعه والعشرون الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ترغب في تقاسم مسؤوليه
رعايه اللاجئين والمهاجرين داخل القاره
الاتفاق الاوروبي الجديد حول ملف الهجره
يحمل في طياته بنودا اكثر صرامه حول توزيع
المسؤوليات بين الدول ومن اهم بلوزه
التزامه الدول غير الراغبه في استقبال
المهاجرين غير الشرعيين واللاجئين على
مساعده الدول المضيفه ماديا ولوجستيان هذا
بالاضافه الى تسريع وتيره استبعاد
المهاجرين واللاجئين غير المسموح لهم
بالبقاء
اسباب عديده حركت المياه الراكده ودفعت في
اتجاه مطالبه العديد من الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي باعاده النظر في طريقه
مواجهه توافد المهاجرين واللاجئين الى
اوروبا وبلغت الهجره غير الشرعيه الى
اوروبا اوجهها سنه 2016 قبل ان تعاود
الارتفاع خلال السنه الماضيه التي وصل
خلالها 330 الف مهاجر غير نظامي الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي عبر جميع الطرق وتتصدر
دول جنوب اوروبا مثل ايطاليا واليونان
الاعضاء الراغبين في وضع خطه جديده لملف
الهجره على اعتبار انها تستقبل العدد
الاكبر من المهاجرين
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
بحضور جماهري كبير في استاد الجوهره نادي
اتحاد جده يقدم لاعبه الجديد كريم بنزيما
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اخبار الساعه
ومشاهدينا نعود الى موضوع حرائق كندا
والضباب البرتقالي الذي وصل الى امريكا
الشماليه وبالتحديد الى نيويورك وغطى
اجوائها ودهور حاله الهواء فيها معنى من
نيويوركا صحفي طارق الشامي طارق اهلا بك
معنا هل انقشع ضباب حرائق كندا عن نيويورك
ام ليس بعد
نعم صهيب الجو الان في نيويورك يعني جو
مطمئن مبدئيا
كثافه الدخان لم تكن
لا تظهر انها مزعجه تبدو كانها ضباب عادي
ولكنها موجوده
والحكومه اعلنت حاله الطوارئ حول ان تلوث
درجه تلوث الهواء ما زالت ما زالت خطره في
اغلب مناطق مدينه نيويورك وضواحيها
الهواء طارق عذرا على المقاطعه يعني هل ما
زالت الانشطه والفعاليات الخارجيه المدارس
هل ما تزال بعض الانشطه موقفه معطله ام لا
اغلب المدن الكبرى في المناطق
الميتروبوليتان المدن الكبرى في شمال شرق
الولايات المتحده اغلقت مدارسها اليوم
تحسبا وقد تغلقها ايضا غدا حاكمه ولايه
نيويورك يعني
أهابت بسكان الولايه ان لا يكونوا جدا
يعني فرحين
بانقشاع هذه الغيمه الدخانيه في الوقت
الحالي لان الحرائق ما زالت مستعره في شرق
كندا وقد وان حركه الرياحيه من سببت تحسين
الاجواء
وانقشاع الدخان ولكن في اي لحظه ربما غدا
او بعد غد قد تعود اسوا مما كانت البارحه
هذا ما كانت تهيب به سكان ليحطاط وياخذ
اعلى درجات الحيطه وكالات الوكالات
الحكوميه تقوم بمراقبه المستشفيات لتسجيل
اي حالات لا سمح الله اختناق او وفاه
نتيجه هذا الدخان ولكن لا يوجد اي تصريحات
حتى الان حول ذلك حاكم ولايه نيوجيرسي
مورفي لك اعلن اليوم ان الولايه سوف تضع
كل ما تملكه من
امكانيات وموارد لمحاربه الحرائق القائمه
الان في غابات يجيرزي ولكن ليست هي خطره
يعني مؤذيه كما يحدث في الشمال شرق طريق
وبالنسبه للرحلات الجويه هل جرى استئنافها
كذلك
اغلب الرحلات الجويه قد استانفت يعني في
اغلب المطارات خاصه في مطار لاغوارديا
ثاني اكبر مطار في نيويورك لكن هناك توجس
وخيفه من عموم السكان يعني
الطابع العام هناك ايثار على البقاء
والابتعاد عن اي فعل غير مسؤول ربما قد
يؤدي بهم الى انتظار ساعات جدا في
المطارات بسبب تاخر الطائرات
هناك ايثار في البقاء في الاماكن المغلقه
في بيوت
واتخاذ الاجراءات الاحتياطيه الملائمه نعم
شكرا جزيلا بشكل عام
عذرا على المقاطعه انتهى وقتي نتابع معك
الحاله الجويه وتحسنها وماده تحسنها في
الايام المقبله ايضا طريق دمشقي شكرا
جزيلا لك مباشره من نيويورك على هذه
الصوره الحيه من هناك مشاهدينا فقط اشير
الى هذا الخبر العاجل الظاهر الان على
شاشه العربيه وكل طاقه الذريه تقول ان
الوضع في
محطه ذا فروجيا نوويه في اوكرانيا ما يزال
خطيرا ومياه سد كخوفكا لا تزال تستخدم
لتبريد محطه النوويه تقول الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
[موسيقى]
قالت المدعيه العامه في مدينه انسي
الفرنسيه
في بيان لها حول حادثه طعام الذي اسفر عن
اصابه اربعه اطفال وشخصين بالغين انه لا
يمكن تحديد اي دافع ارهابي من الحادثه
واشارتس في بيانها الى ان مكتب المدعي
العام يقوم بالاجراءات اللازمه حول الامر
كما قلت سابقا لا يمكننا تحديد اي دافع
ارهابي حول حادثه الطعن في مدينه انسي
كالعاده بالنسبه لهذا النوع من الحوادث
مكتب المدعي العام موجود ويقوم بالاجراءات
اللازمه حول الامر المشتبه به لاجئ سياسي
وهو حاليا مشرد في مدينه انسي واتضح لنا
انه وصل الى المدينه في خريف عام 2022
واود التاكيد على ان المشتبه به كان يحمل
سلاحا واحدا فقط وقد تمت مصادرته على
الفور
زميلنا حسين قنيبر وصل الى مدينه انسي
التي وقع فيها هذا الهجوم الغريب الحقيقه
حسين اهلا بك معنا ما الذي استقيته من
معلومات حول دوافع هذا الهجوم عنا لا يوجد
اي مبرر منطقي لهذا الهجوم على اطفال
بالسكين
مساء الخير صهيب اتفقوا معك في توصيف هذه
الجريمه بالغريبه لانها المره الاولى اولا
لانه ليس هناك ما يبررها على الاطلاق وحتى
لو كانت هناك تبريرات فلا شيء يبرر الهجوم
على اطفال هذا غير مسبوق في تاريخ فرنسا
الحديث على الاقل من هذا المكان جاء
المعتدي او وقفز فوق سور الحديد المحيط
بهذه الحديقه وهو يصرخ بكلام غير مفهوم
عند الساعه التاسعه والدقيقه الاربعين
تماما من صباح اليوم هنا في انسي كان هناك
اطفال على عرباتهم ومعهم ذووهم فبدا
يستخدم سكينه ضد اول الطفل استهدفها كان
طفلا هولنديا يبلغ من العمر 22 شهرا ثم
انقض بس على طفل بريطاني كان مع ذويه ايضا
كالهولندي الطفل البريطاني يبلغ من العمر
عامين ثم انقضى بسكينه ايضا على طفلين
شقيقين فرنسيين اخ يبلغ من العمر عامين
واخته تبلغ ثلاثه اعوام ثم هاجم رجلا مسنا
فاصابه بجراح خطي ولكن حسين هذه تفاصيل
مروعه لهذه الجريمه قد يجعله يفعل ذلك
حسين ما الذي يجعل شخصا يذهب في الصباح
الى حديقه ويطعن اطفال صغار بهذه الاعمار
وزير الداخليه جيرال درمنا الذي حضر الى
هنا تماما كما رئيسه الوزراء
اليزابيث بورن قال درمنا ان المصادفه
محيره بين هذه الجريمه وبين تبلغ هذا
المعتدي عن رفض السلطات الفرنسيه طلب لجوء
كان تقدم به طلب لجوء ثاني له خلال عده
اشهر
المعتدي قدم نفسه على انه مسيحي من سوريا
يدعى عبد المسيح وعثر بحوزته على بطاقه
هويه تؤكد انه من سوريا طبعا التحقيق
سيحدد ما اذا كانت بطاقه الهويه عائده له
فعلا ولكن وسائل اعلام فرنسيه اتصلت مع
طليقته في السويد او من مع من زعمت انها
طليقته فقالت انه بالفعل مسيحي من سوريا
مهم
في دوله اوروبيه اخرى في السويد يعني
بمعنى انه دخوله الى فرنسا وطلوبه طلبه
لللجوء يعني
فرنسا ليست اول دوله اوروبيه يدخل لها هذا
الشخص
هي رابع دوله اوروبيه يقدم فيها طلب لجوء
طلب وهنا الغرابه قبل طلب لجوء كما تقدم
فيه به في سويسرا ثم في ايطاليا ثم في
السويد التي عاش فيها عشره سنوات وهناك بل
تعرف في تركيا على من تزوجها لاحقا وعاشا
معها في السويد لمده خمس سنوات ثم انفصل
عنها قبل ثمانيه اشهر له منها طفل في
الثالثه من عمره وهو العمر نفسه تقريبا
الذي كان يعيشه هؤلاء بل اقل من ثلاث
سنوات ضحاياه عنهم اليوم عليهم هنا في هذا
المكان الذي ما زال
نعم ما زال الفرنسيون والسياح يتقاتلون
على هذا المكان الذي وقعت فيه الجريمه
المروعه اشاره الى انه كان تقدم لدى وصوله
الى فرنسا في الخريف الماضي بطلب لجوء اول
ورفض طلب اللجوء هذا في فرنسا ثم تقدم هذا
العام بطلب لجوء الثاني هذا
[موسيقى]
الجيش الاسرائيلي الليله الماضيه منزله
اسلام الفروخ الذي تتهمه اسرائيل بتنفيذ
عمليه تفجير في القدس العام الماضي وكانت
عشرات المركبات العسكريه اقتحمت مدينه رام
الله وحاصرت المنزل ثم قامت بتفجيره واصيب
سته فلسطينيين بالرصاص المطاطي والغاز
المسيل للدموع خلال المواجهات التي اندلعت
خلال عمليه الهدم
قبل انتصاف الليل بقليل عشرات الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه تدخل مدينه رام الله
باتجاه بلدتها القديمه
الهدف هدم منزل يعود لعائله الفروخ بتهمه
ان ابنها اسلام خطط ونفذ عمليتين في القدس
العام الماضي قتل خلالهما مستوطنا
البيت هذا بنى
في سنه
1990 تقريبا
تعبنا احنا والوالد الله يرحم الوالد تعب
فيه لمن بناه واحنا تعبنا فيه
سياسه العقاب الجماعي هاي انا بنصح
الاحتلال ما يستمر فيها لانه من 70 سنه
وهو يمارس هاي السياسه لا تسمن ولا تغني
من جوع
[موسيقى]
الجيش الاسرائيلي نشر صورا لعمليه تلغيم
المنزل ثم تفجيره
تنفيذا لقرار وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
الذي يجري هو اعاده احتلال كامل للضفه
الغربيه سواء كان ذلك منطقه الف منطقه باء
منطقه جيم واضح تماما ان هذه الحكومه في
اسرائيل تعيد احتلال كامل مفاصل الضفه
الغربيه الجيش الاسرائيلي اعتقل عددا من
الفلسطينيين خلال مواجهات عنيفه بين الجيش
والفلسطينيين الذين حاولوا منع عمليه
الهدم هذا الركام يضاف الى ركام قرابه
الستين منزلا هدمها الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ
بدايه العام في اجراء يراه الفلسطينيون
عقابا جماعيا يطال ابسط حقوق الانسان
من منزل الفروخ في رام الله التحتا خالد
القاسم العربيه
[موسيقى]
اذا اظهرت صور جديده حجم ثوراني بركان
كيلويا احد البراكين النشطه في جزيره
واهو اكبر جزر
بهذا اخبار الساعه شكرا لكم على كرم
المشاهده دائما على العربيه على صفحاتنا
على مواقع التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات